i am deeply worried about it one
at one of the hearings i chaired we had
testimony from a guy
named named dr epstein oh yeah i know
about it um
and he's a psychologist used to be the
editor of psychology today
he's an academic he's by the way not a
conservative he's a liberal democrat
who voted for hillary clinton and openly
supported hillary clinton and and he did
empirical research on google's
manipulative search outcomes so it's
interesting psychology
when you type in a search the
autocorrect
the auto fill in not the autocorrect but
what automatically populates
makes a huge difference
and the first few stories that come up
make a huge difference and there was a
dramatic differential
between when you typed in hillary
clinton it would auto populate good
things yeah all good things yeah
when you typed in donald trump it would
auto populate bad things and the stories
that would come up
would be predominantly good stories for
hillary predominantly bad stories
uh for trump and what was interesting is
is
dr epstein did the study and he
concluded that in 2016
google's uh deceptive
search outcomes shifted 2.4
million votes to hillary clinton
and he said this as a hillary clinton
supporter but he was he was horrified
but he also
projected he said in 2015 he said big
tech is getting worse it's getting more
aggressive they could move as many as
15 million votes
to the democrats in 2020 and and so i
think it's a
huge threat in fact i know your answer
to this but do you think these things
should be fought on multiple fronts
meaning
there can be a more conservative answer
there can be a more libertarian answer
that's more free market i mean that's
why i started locals it was like
when i i've had this disagreement with
tucker carlson on his show where he
wants
the government to do it and i said well
i'm going to try the free market side
i don't have a problem with that
argument because it's like maybe we all
have to hit it
in different ways look the prager you
guys that you work with they got into a
lawsuit with youtube
is is dennis's or i don't want to speak
for dennis but is the prageru
ethos like let's use the law to stop
companies from doing something of course
not but we're all
we're all trying to navigate very murky
waters and isn't that the freest market
of all
is to try all of these different
solutions to the problem
you're not going to be able to take down
this
monstrous left-wing edifice
with one little narrow pure solution
that that one little narrow pure
solution might help but you're going to
need a lot of
different strategies a lot of different
tactics to undertake and so
certainly everything should be on the
table you don't want to do anything that
is objectively wrong
i'm not advocating that in any way but
if
if once we shouldn't just burn down the
google servers i think they're somewhere
in utah we shouldn't just go there and
light them up in the name of social
justice yeah yeah no we probably
shouldn't do that
but but certainly i mean what you've
done with locals is a great example
right certainly we can innovate
we can create try to create our own
institutions at least create the
beginnings of our own institutions
and enforce the law that is already on
the books
those two things are not contradictory
to one another and actually
if we do enforce the law if we do have a
credible threat of enforcing the law if
we do have a credible threat of a
competitor to one of these organizations
that is going to increase the likelihood
of success on all fronts you know
when you've got something like a google
and when you add in all the other tech
companies they control the flow of
internet
that is an amount of power that i don't
think
anybody who is who cares deeply about
the country or any of the founding
fathers or any people who've thought
about
how this republic is supposed to work i
don't think they would be comfortable
with that kind of power
being consolidated whether it's in a
technically a private company or not
well i i do think silicon valley has
shifted
a lot over over the years when i was in
an undergraduate at stanford in the late
1980s
stanford was sort of a very liberal
politically correct place
but the silicon valley surrounding not
so much it was
vaguely libertarian uh you know it was
it was a moderate republican
congressional district
and um and then sort of by the late 90s
i would say it shifted to being sort of
a
moderate um moderate democrat which was
around the time i started paypal
and if you fast forward another 20 years
it's sort of um
it's it's it's sort of a pretty hard
left yeah so what do you think
what do you think because it seems to me
that if i was taking the people that i
wanted to be the most creative
the most outside the box the most to
look at the system and go how do we fix
the system from the outside
you'd want a lot of libertarian thinkers
that's that's the way i would at least
look at it
so you'd think that everyone in silicon
valley would be pretty
libertarian they want to do things on
their own and yet somehow in those 20
years
it it became the opposite well it's it's
like when you ask a question
why is it why is it so uh so left when i
think these things are you know
they're somewhat over determined so i
would say uh
part of it is um is that it's probably
the most
educated part of the country in terms of
how much time people spent in college
and i think one of the downsides of too
much education is that you get
the most brainwashed and so it's it's
the most educated
can also mean that it is it is the it is
the most brainwashed
uh you know um this is perhaps not so
true of the founders but
certainly of um of many of the the rank
and file people
who are um you know if you're sort of
like a really good engineer
or um you know really good at some
specific thing
your education typically does not
involve you thinking that much about
about politics and so it's not
necessarily from
deep ideological conviction it's often
more as a fashion statement
than as a question of of power so uh and
so one of the things that's always a
little bit hard to score is that even if
you took a survey
in silicon valley it's it's it comes out
as you know quite far to the left
you know weirdly um uniform weird sort
of group thing
it's uh super hard to know whether
people really believe this
whether they're whether they're just
going along right so i
i think it's pretty liberal but um but
of course not as liberal as it looks and
that's
that's in a way worse because it means
people are you know too scared to
to articulate things right there was a
there was a dinner i had at my house
a week before the 2016 election with a
group of sort of center-right
silicon valley people one of them was uh
is a very prominent angel investor in
silicon valley
and he said um uh you know i'm voting
for trump
in a week but because i live in silicon
valley i'm lying about it
and so uh while he's saying this to you
four people there yeah and uh and uh
you're like i'm the guy that just spoke
at the convention
he was honest about lying yeah this is
unusual a little bit unusual yeah
and um and the way i lie is i tell
people i'm voting for gary johnson the
libertarian so if like he couldn't he
couldn't quite get away
telling people that he was voting for
hillary clinton because
like your facial muscles wouldn't work
and people could tell you're lying but
small eye gary johnson that was sort of
what you what you could do
yeah and uh and i think you know if you
sort of looked at
what happened in the weeks before the
election the uh the gary johnson support
sort of collapsed it all went to trump
and the uh
the question you have to ask is whether
uh
do those people just change their minds
the last minute or
were they lying all along or were they
lying to themselves
and and so i think the the sort of
political correctness
you know it's always bad for thought but
it always makes things appear more
uniform
than they are even in silicon valley
first thing we talk about tech
is we also have we have to first admit
we really don't have a market in tech
there's a couple reasons behind this and
then we have to talk about some of the
problems that i think everyone admits
first of all there's a lot of cronyism
that exists between the big tech
companies right now
whether it be government contracts
whether it be far too extended patents
that are given to google
when you think about this i think that
patents in a lot of ways are anti-free
market
and i think we should shrink the window
of how long some of these patents are so
you said it the best
google has this algorithm that no one
can figure out right but they also have
a patented
and they have a patented for a very long
time and so if it were to be
put off the patent market well it's also
made public
and someone could compete against it so
that's an interesting thing to think
about
that there could be a free that they're
actually hiding behind some of the
government favors that are given
right so it's a weird place to be though
because you're sort of asking for
government interference
with the hope of this back end freedom
so let's
let let's go to what we want yeah i
think let's let i always
tell our team at turning point usa every
every time what does success look like
well charlie success looks like 1400
high school kids in dc
in august great how do we get that we
work backwards to where we are today
let's let's do that why not take me on
this voyage what does success look like
fair free and open platforms with
different ideas can express themselves
multiple tech companies not four but
dozens of tech companies competing for
our interests that are able to
you know have um these ideas present
hopefully an improving product over time
and hopefully a search engine that
doesn't have 92 percent of the market
share
i don't think that's a healthy thing i
just don't i think even 40
would be a lot 90 so that that's where a
success would look like a disaggregation
let's call it that or decentralization i
think that's probably a fair we would
agree with that right
and also you not having to battle
youtube non-stop and you're not having
to do all these things
you actually focus on content creation i
have to ask you dave how many hundreds
of hours have you spent of wasted energy
on this stuff oh it's been i mean i have
to fight them publicly constantly it's
like
it's not fun right yeah well it's not
fun it's it's not that it's
it's bad business because i'm putting
cow content that i end up losing money
on
i'm in a weird way there are times where
i'm doing the producers the more things
that i make the more money i lose yes
which is not fun but also it's just
publicly
it's not fun to have to attack the your
own your own platform but okay so so far
i'm with you on the ideas but now where
we're gonna have our problem is here's
the here's the question the functional
part
is the the question is so let's say we
deregulate some of the patent stuff
but is it enough and i'm at a place
right now
where target carlson said something
really interesting to me and really
stuck with me
i said charlie i want you to think about
this who is more powerful the irs or
google
and i immediately said the irs because
that's what we conservatives believe
like
we believe that government has uniform
power and i defended it i thought pretty
well
google doesn't have the power of audits
google can't put you in prison
you know all these irs can do all those
sorts of things right and irs can wreck
your business
and tucker retorted with a really
interesting thing he said well but
google can't shut down your business
yeah i guess that's right and i debated
a little bit and google can
manipulate entire society to believe
something might not be true
and we went to the whole litany of how
powerful google was and i thought about
it for months
and i think that's really important
thing that we conservatives do we
actually are always challenging our
positions i think that's what's so
healthy about
our movement and it hit me about a month
and a half ago
when i was using i had my laptop open
and i had my gmail account
watching youtube you know on my google
calendar
yeah and i said my goodness they know
everything about me
the irs doesn't know crap the irs knows
a couple bank statements you know my
taxes and my bank statements
that's a very small picture of my actual
activity and i thought to myself when i
might this computer open i said
what if one engineer in google was
flipping through twitter and saw one of
my tweets praising president trump
and he said screw this charlie kirk guy
i'm going and he goes to work tomorrow
and he decides to look at everything
about me
do we know that's not happening i mean i
think we can go on the assumption that
it is happening
really scary that's more power than the
nsa haves
and by the way we know that google is so
slanted in the wrong direction
ideologically
we know they've shown regret for not
doing enough in 2016. we know the
political imbalance their political
contributions were over a million
dollars to hillary clinton
and zero dollars to donald trump in 2016
as far as political contributions
they fired james de moray so here's the
question is is there a place
for the federal government to get
engaged or involved tinker on the edges
or chain or
do something to change the way that this
is currently happening
you know what's interesting to me is
that it's generally
people um on the left who are saying
this
or on the right who are getting kind of
throttled but on the left it's like get
them all off
ban them all it's not the public square
but i think
that what it hurts um really
marginalized people the most of course
they trickle down and so i don't know
it to not consider it the public square
is dangerous in some ways because then
you are really it's like
but it's the it's just so crazy to me
it's just but
it goes to show how you're not gay
because you don't think the right way
someone is can
isn't black if they don't think the
right way it's the ideology so
if you have the right ideology you'll be
allowed in the public square well that's
not the public square
but it is weird with facebook and all
these places because
um as far as i'm concerned
just being that they're private
companies even if they were smart enough
to create a public square they still get
to do what they want to do
yeah i mean i i don't know what else to
say about that that's just
that sucks do you think the ship has
totally sailed with big tech that we're
basically just
at the end of it now like you know we
all are on borrowed time there basically
no uh but i think that you know
at any time you have any industry it's
going to at first ossify into like four
to ten
you know major establishments it was the
case in publishing you know he had six
companies is the case in music you know
he had a certain number of labels
but after a certain time like in music
like in self publishing and in
the internet uh they might have a
disproportionate amount of impact on the
market but they're not going to have
that monopoly control
uh that we're seeing to some extent now
the only people there's a very few
people who are like completely
you know driven off the internet uh the
rest they're having issues with it
and the fact that you are creating a
competitive advantage alternative to
them
really is an issue because just if i'm
not political
why would i if i have to choose between
patreon and locals right and they're
both
comparable in their advantages but this
has the disadvantage of i might lose my
account
overnight for some political reason
whereas here that's not going to be a
concern
and i'm going to have a similar ability
to attract audiences why wouldn't i go
to this other one
because this is directly effect i mean
it's been a sort of through line of
everything we've been talking about here
but it's also directly affected your
channel so the prageru channel
you guys and again you're doing videos
to explain things i've watched
many many of your videos right i'm in
one next month that's right i mean
so i've never seen any hatred people
could argue with
some of the facts if they want or they
could argue with maybe you're coming
from a certain political persuasion or
any of that but i've never seen anything
remotely close to hate speech or hatred
or any of the stuff that would get you
banned or whatever you guys were
you weren't banned from twitter but you
were restricted
yes so you can't show it in schools or
libraries
i mean what do you do what do you think
it's mind-blowing we have a video on the
origins of the korean war yeah
what why is that restricted yeah
so what's happening here with look this
show is on youtube so i don't want to
make the youtube gods
uh too angry no they they won't be angry
yeah
but uh it's a very look that i
i was sure the wall street journal had a
featured editorial on behalf of prager
university
yeah i thought uh saying what is youtube
doing what are you nuts
because a lot of wall street journal
people uh have you know brexit
brett stephens has done one uh kimberly
strassel has done one and others
and so they know about us
what are you what are you kidding uh
youtube what are you nuts
so what do you think is actually
happening well i know what some leftists
are meeting at the top of youtube no no
no i think that there are leftists to
troll
the uh uh the webs the websites
especially among those that are
successful and and
we're the biggest producer of
conservative videos in the world
and 220 million views last year that's a
serious number for anybody even for the
left
yeah and and so they know that we exist
and so if one bugs them then uh
you know they just you know say uh i
don't know
bad material or objectionable or hateful
and if they get enough of those there's
an algorithm that says okay we got
we got reports they don't i don't think
they sit there
they don't monitor them right they get
they get
feedback and so leftists who want to
shut us down
send this feedback but it it but once
they're contacted once the wall street
journal
they then had another editorial they
have three editorials on behalf of
prairie university in the wall street
journal that's a big newspaper
and of course not one liberal newspaper
has but so they're not liberal they're
left a liberal paper would come to our
defense right do you notice
that the norms and standards to quote
the atlantic
of american life seems to have changed
overnight
and all of a sudden we are being told we
must accept things that would have been
completely unimaginable
two months ago
well tucker there's so much to talk
about here first off i didn't realize i
was going to be on a sci-fi show tonight
but we are
entering a dystopian future we are
entering
an authoritarian future because as i've
said to you before
authoritarians love authoritarianism so
they're taking this opportunity
when we're all confused we're all locked
at home the only way we can communicate
with each other
is through their pipes is through
youtube and facebook and twitter
and everything else and they're actually
finally saying to us this
is who we are i mean the atlantic is
ridiculous i i don't know anyone that
reads it anymore
but but the bigger issue here is is the
youtube
twitter facebook component of it because
we are now
saying to them or or they're saying to
us
we're going to tell you what's true and
if you dare
go against what we say is true not
necessarily what is true but what we
say is true then we're going to boot you
so
the the of course the other part of this
is that it will always only be one side
that gets booted here i mean
is facebook running around and is
twitter and youtube running around
are they taking away all the russian
collusion videos that were up over the
past couple years i'm pretty sure msnbc
has a youtube channel that still has
videos on it i mean that was pushing
lies and misinformation
and propaganda so we need to debate
these things
if i was to interview these two doctors
that you showed the video of
would my channel be deleted am i not
allowed to talk about that is that not
what science
and open inquiry really is about that
you test theories and then you find out
what actually is true
and as you pointed out and this may be
the most important part it's not as if
the who is infallible they were
literally just
a few weeks ago telling us not to wear
masks now by law i tried to go to cvs
yesterday
and i wasn't going to wear a mask i was
just going to run in and out and it said
in the front of the store
it said by law you have to wear a mask
so it's not as if these people have some
uh you know some total stranglehold on
truth that the rest of us have to bow to
unless they force us to and
unfortunately big tech has got us now
more than ever because we're all trapped
at home and it's the only way we can
communicate
so no one in science has a monopoly on
the truth science in fact
is a rejection of the idea that there is
a monopoly on truth it's the endless
search
for what we can prove that's what
science is they this has nothing to do
with it
you introduced as a hypothetical the
notion that you could be deleted your
channel for hosting this video i'm not
sure that is hypothetical anymore and my
question is very simple
how long before they come for you you
just wrote a book called don't burn this
book
how long before they come for the show
sincere questions
yeah uh well i s at some level i don't
want to think about it but you know
tucker you've written a couple books and
you know that the publishing process
takes quite some time so i finished this
book back in july
but i'm very proud that the ideas that i
present and don't burn this book are
more relevant now
than they even were then because i talk
about
big tech i talk about fake news all of
the things that we're constantly talking
about and am i worried
yeah i'm worried i mean look any
everyone should be worried
everyone should be worried this is why i
started locals.com my tech company
because i think we need digital homes
anyone that's online and you think
that youtube or facebook or twitter is
there to protect you
you're the product i mean these things
are free except free meaning they just
took your soul in exchange for it uh we
should own our data you should own your
own content
we need to start rethinking everything i
mean i think this is why
i'm actually quite enthused about the
world right now is as depressing and
upsetting as some of the news is
you know there's a new world coming on
the horizon and i think a lot of people
are rethinking
the way they look at the world the way
do you want to commute do you want to
live in a big city
do you want to be so reliant on the
institutions and systems
that we've always been relying on so i
think we have to rethink things and
you know what tucker this is still
america for a little while and i believe
in old-fashioned hard work and
competition engineer and
ingenuity and i think that's what will
fix this but yeah we're we got a
we got a big battle to fight in front of
us government
is about to become
unless it marries into it
pretty inconsequential because it will
never be able to keep up
with technology so is that the saving
grace here
no not not that i was going to give
google a lot of
the left is concentrating their power in
silicon valley
and that's where you can really
silence people the guy who wrote ibm and
the holocaust
um gosh i can't remember his name
really brilliant guy well thought out
um we were talking and um
talking about how the germans how they
silence people and how they they
cordoned people off and then just get
smaller and smaller groups and then they
eventually put you behind a wall
in a ghetto well
they would build the wall higher and
higher so people couldn't hear
or see isn't that what google and
facebook
are doing we're building digital ghettos
we
have the ability now you can speak all
you
want dave but i'm changing the algorithm
and you're not going to be heard i mean
you look at what the deal with facebook
was
i promote them i give them my
10 million listeners and i say hey you
can find me at facebook
let's communicate then they take those
listeners
that said i want to hear from him
and then they change the algorithm and i
can't communicate to my own people
yeah and we know this is happening
across the board you probably saw my
insane tweet thread about all
i just started retweeting all of these
people real people not russian bots
and avatars i was taking purposely real
people with real names or real pictures
and they're all saying they're
unsubscribed there were people who pay
it wasn't just the free people it was
the people who pay for youtube red or
youtube tv
still getting unsubscribed then it's
like what did we all
sign up for here but dare i do you like
the biblical analogies i'll do one here
there was david verse goliath and i
think dave can take down google
this dave i think there's a chance i
mean i think that story i'm being
slightly hyperbolic obviously but i
think that these things have become
so big i mean this i guess is what the
essence of the story was right
that this goliath this google has become
so big that it will crumble under its
own
under the weight of its own crap
basically that there will be enough
people
inside the broken machine that will wake
up
that i hope that individuals basically i
hope
all you got is hope right yeah and
you're you're three to five years away
from it being a cage
i mean their behavior with china which i
outline in the book
is pretty horrific what china what the
road
china is going down is terrifying and
google
is right there with them and that is
evil
that is evil they say don't be evil well
that is the definition
of it um and if they just slowly
you know the guy who closes the door on
the gas
chamber was most likely a guy that was
fixing
trucks before the war in a normal guy
you don't
suddenly become evil you slowly move
into it
especially if you're surrounded by a
group of people that are all
absolutely convinced that they are right
and the other voice is wrong and
therefore
we just have to filter them out
with a.i and the way they are gobbling
um it's really disturbing the reason i
always do this
is because this is the only course of i
don't like doing it
but it's the only course of action we
have and this is then where
i think some of the lefties would say
and now some of the trump people would
say
government regulation they own all the
pipes they own all the information
so i'll say this um
i said earlier i would welcome
regulation against twitter
because i believe it's becoming so
detrimental especially after talking to
jack
and uh um vijaya that that really tells
you how the conversation went
well they they looked me in the eyes and
said we are going to do what we think is
right
we are an unelected listen twitter is an
unelected council of the uber elite
millionaires who are dictating what
people can or can't say on one of the
most important public platforms
in our country in the world who who who
determined they should have that
influence over our elections
i don't like uh citizens united and yes
i understand the nuances with
you know taking away the right to speech
through money means that best media
companies will hold too much power it's
complicated
i don't want billionaires dictating our
elections i don't want oligopolies
forming and i certainly don't want
twitter
joining their party i see them say this
and i say you know what maybe the best
thing would be a sledgehammer right now
because the debate is is basically over
they said they said basically
we allow speech on our platform if you
follow our rules well we know
people are getting elected through your
platform and you've excised a large
portion of the population
knock it down i've been looking for a
great way to do this and i'm glad that i
connected with you we're launching today
my platform on locals and starting
the tulsi community on locals
it's it's gonna be a great place to uh
hang out in hawaii we call it talk story
hey let's go talk story
uh which really is just like let's
exchange ideas let's share our stories
with each other let's get to know each
other better
and see how we can come up with great
ideas constructive policies
different things that that we can do
both in our own ways as individuals in
our own communities in our own circles
but also
how we can work together to further
advance
um the ideas and values that that are
fundamental
uh to our country so uh it'll be a
i'm i'm excited about it because it'll
be a great place for
like-minded people to come together and
have these discussions hang
out you know i like to cook i know you
do too
it's not going to be all politics i
don't think anybody can stand all
politics but
it'll be a great place to share
conversation
exclusive content i'll find my best
recipes and and share a few with people
every
last my most recent one was uh a
beautiful
uh vegan miso shiitake ramen
and uh i posted that on instagram and
people were like oh my god that looks
amazing share the recipe so
it'll be a fun place to gather together
and have some real conversation make
friends hang out
and uh be free from the concerns and
constraints that
a lot of us feel you know i i think very
carefully
before i put out a tweet because you
have to um
this will be a place where we can all
kind of just just relax a little bit
more and and
know that we are amongst friends yeah
awesome well i'm obviously thrilled that
you're part of it and just to be clear
so
the direct link of course is
tulsi.locals.com
and i just want to be clear for for
everyone watching this i
although i did start locals i have no
control over any of this stuff
tulsi it's her community we we just
basically built you the house
and now you go ahead and do whatever you
want in that house and have whatever
exchanges you want to have and post your
food picks and your
your search i sense there's going to be
some surfing videos
as well there has to be do you sense
that
generally that this will be the
direction the internet is going that
that's been my inkling for the last
couple years which is why i started
local is that the big tech thing
we went from too big to fail to too big
to succeed and i just felt you know if
we could just
treat the internet the way we treat our
own lives in that everyone
can have a house but you don't have to
invite everyone in your house to do
whatever they want that that to me seems
like the right way
is that is that kind of why you jumped
on board this thing besides me harassing
you about it for a couple weeks
no it's it's i think it is um it's it's
to me
especially i mean you you had foresight
and you saw this
perhaps a lot early the need for
something like this a lot earlier than
others
but again i think the events of this
last week like you have been having a
ton of conversations with people who are
really thinking about
how we can break through and make sure
that
we have these not just alternatives but
really new platforms that encourage you
know independent thinking and
freedom of thought freedom of speech
like who knew that
such ideas would be cutting edge in the
world that we happen to be living in
today and something that we actively
have to
uh create platforms for
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about tech
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our tech playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell